and I want to ask you I know you talked
about music all the time I just um I
just wanted cuz I just have a big peak
because I'm a fan right is that when you
when it when you went before your first
album came out Interpol did you know
that it was gonna kill it the way it did
no not in terms of having a commercial
you know reaction and I think we're
actually fortunate as the strokes broke
and so then like indie rock was having
this moment out of New York City and
everybody was ready for you know new
indie rock from New York City right I
think that helped as far as like how
widely we were received yeah but what I
did really know was that that everybody
in the band was really talented and when
we had our when we got our final lineup
with Sam our drummer and we had Carlos I
was you know I just felt like these guys
are you know if we need more than this
and I don't know yeah I felt very
confident that we were capable of doing
great music but like you have no who
knows how it's gonna you know be
received right but when that when the
critics because it was so critically
acclaimed the first one was yeah yeah
yeah and people just loved it and it's
like I just don't know I feel like that
that just for your first album to have
that kind of [ __ ] key it must feel so
good you know I mean it's like but this
your sophomore album though usually
there's a slump they say right yeah I'm
sorry I mean this is a out album that
you started yeah you know antics right
is in many ways better than the first is
great but to follow it up with antics
was like oh my god like they're
consistent you know I mean did you
that's would you feel good about antics
for sure yeah yeah that was a great
phase in the band and I think we we had
an idea we were super mindful of the
sophomore slump thing and also I
remember being very mindful of not
waiting too long to get the second one
out which we had to have like band
meetings about because Carlos kind of
wanted a break in that period of time
and I had a sense that like you know we
really got to do the like the one-two
punch so to speak yeah things that you
just said so I think we were you know
aware and I think we did the right thing
at that time but I like the direction
now though Co it's experimental cool
it's right I mean it's like that lat I
forget the last album with Marauder
Marauder right it's so good like some of
its like cuz you I know you like like
sometimes when you listen to early
Blonde Redhead or whatever right oh man
what a bad yeah I love that [ __ ] bad
- oh my god I love that band yeah but
early Blonde Redhead it's like see how
cool you say something hey will clip it
will clip it I'll sit down right but
it's like you know especially the
earlier stuff is kind of noisy or like
but you can hear the melody like or the
chorus is so melodic when it was there
was noise and then the melody of the
chorus hits you it has that vibe to it
that Marauders there's a call that's
cool yeah yeah that's cool yeah we're
all we've toured with them we're
friendly with the members of Blonde
Redhead yeah what's her name again kazoo
kazoo yeah she Asian yeah fold not fall
though I think so I think she's Japanese
oh she is I think so what a [ __ ]
weird voice huh so good but it blends so
well with his cuz his voice has got that
high register and then yeah like higher
but then Quinn the boys are twins right
yeah yeah yeah so talented I played a
song with them off of the record that
was called 21 or had a song called 21
and dr. Strangelove was on that record
with the tennis racket one with the girl
right yeah yeah yeah I played live with
him sorry to learn one of their songs
and it's just like dude you're a genius
oh my god yeah he's a really great
songwriter and then one of the greatest
drummers I think in all of indie rock as
well oh wow because it's been to the
other Blood Brothers yeah yeah they're
they're on another yeah that one album
forgot was but it had just you'll
probably know it it has six red blocks
in it something about lemons in it yeah
dad album it is commercial - it's not as
noisy as a previous stuff but every song
is so [ __ ] good in that album I think
it's cool you know they've become a meme
really that do you know that no no they
and I don't know if it was Rick and
Morty that started it but now like
online that if there's ever like a clip
where someone kind of dies inside they
play like that
yeah yeah one redhead oh well it is yeah
I don't think they knew that that was
happening and I told I think I informed
them that like you know yeah I mean are
they nice oh they're the nicest people
yeah would you say that we're nice yes I
mean I feel like I know all of you from
watching the show yeah I was gonna ask
you a couple things are you ever gonna
put out some music how seriously do you
take before he answers that we've
actually been trying to UM steal his
iPad for the past three months because
we want to extract a lot of his music
this guy stays up for hours every night
just writing songs on GarageBand and I
think they're brilliant but he doesn't
think so so he just keeps deleting them
but before he does I want to take no I I
don't know I bring it to the cloud you
did the the there's like the intro theme
and the outro theme right yeah you're
barely on the YouTube one yeah that's
yeah yeah yeah it's great I know but
it's it's four cores you know I mean you
know it's not it's not here's what it is
you know that doesn't for you know four
chords three chords two chords you know
it doesn't matter right they work for me
they work for me is like that it's clear
that you could do longer form pieces of
music again here's a thing here's the
thing here's the thing right like when
you write a song write it like it maybe
it'll start with a D minor and then
you'll let use diminished notes right
not knowingly but sure I don't know any
music here alright wow so it's
instinctual yeah then yeah but you'll
use a diminished chord I'm like yeah I
would never use that I'm not a music guy
but I do know how me like especially
when modern pop music generally it's for
four core three or four chords and
they're beat people use the same ones
over and over again it's just in terms
of tempo or how you use it you know and
um you know so I know the basics but you
know I'm blushing right now um you know
maybe one day you know I can grab your
email maybe I could send you some stuff
love I'd love to hear that would be I
think lovin the fact that you're saying
you know that you're noticing the
diminished chord I mean you're you know
you're tuned into that's just sort of
like having aesthetics and and that's
what you would apply to your writing so
I feel why you're you're tuned in to the
nuances of writing good and emotive
music yeah I think you should do it
thank you
yeah I think it has a lot to do with
also just me you know there's a
difference between you know I've always
said this is two people there's a
difference between like being a
technical musician and being like The
Velvet Underground right
sometimes a band like development yeah
it's sometimes it's very primitive it's
like just you know Moe Tucker just
you're banging the thing but sometimes
it represents a culture right and
they're talking about things that's
never been talked about before like SNM
or about you know transgender issues
back in the sixties right about feeling
you know suicidal or whatnot right
there's just you know and the Interpol
is one of those bands that just is just
hit at a time where it was just like it
was just it just fits your the culture
and um you guys are up there a man with
them you know and I thank you you're
welcome
you mentioned some bands earlier and I
wanted to say that I mean it's such an
honor to be even considered in and
because I know what you mean about the
impact that those other bands that you
mentioned had like on me for instance so
of how you know them to be and you look
in the mirror you know you think I know
your people make dinner early people
make assumptions you gets a lot
[Music]